- [Voiceover] 7 pounds of plums
make 8 rolls of fruit leather.
If every batch of fruit leather requires
the same amount of plums,
how many pounds of plums are required
to make 20 rolls of fruit leather?
So, let's set up a ratio.
We need 7 pounds
of plums for every 8 rolls,
8 rolls of fruit leather.
Now, we need to think
about how many pounds
of plums we're gonna need.
How many pounds of plums we're gonna need
to make 20 rolls of fruit leather.
20 rolls of fruit leather.
Well, let's see.
What have we done?
To go from 8 rolls to 20 rolls,
how many times do we have to,
how much larger is 20 than 8?
Let's see, 20 divided by
8 is 2 and four-eighths,
which is 2 and a half.
So, we multiplied by 2 and a half,
or we have 2 and a half
times as many rolls
when we go from 8 to 20.
So we're going to need 2 and
a half times as many pounds
to keep the ratios constant.
So, times 2.5,
and what's 7 times 2.5?
Well, let's see.
7 times 2 is 14.
7 times 5 is 3.5.
14 plus 3.5, this is going to be,
this is going to be 17.5 pounds.
And that's this choice right over here.
And actually, even looking at the choices,
you might have been able to get here
even without doing this.
Not too intensive mathematics.
Because you can say, okay look,
the pounds are kind of close
to the amount of leather.
But they're less than it.
So, we wouldn't want 23 pounds of plums
if we make 20 rolls of fruit leather.
This is more than 20.
And if we're making, if
we're making more rolls
than the 7 pounds, than
we were able to make
with the 7 pounds,
we're not gonna be able to
have fewer pounds there.
So you could have actually
ruled out all of them
just based on the logic to get to 17.5.
But it's always satisfying
to do it the right way.
All right, but if you're
under time pressure,
you know, deductive reasoning
isn't always a bad thing.